Greg, Paul, congratulations.
You've managed to make
it into the third round
of this competition, and
you are one step closer
to the title of "Forged
in Fire" champion
and a check for $10,000.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges,
where you will recreate an
iconic weapon from history.
That weapon is-- the makraka.
The makraka is a
sickle-shaped weapon
with its cutting edge on the
inside curve of the blade.
It was notably used
by the Azande tribe,
a dangerous clan that invaded
and conquered central Africa
in the early 1800s.
With the help of
the makraka, they
took no prisoners
while defending
their land and resources.
The sword was often
used in executions
to remove limbs, and decapitate
intruders or enemies.
The Azandes' fatal and
terrorizing use of the makraka
is highlighted in the game
"The Deadliest Warrior."
You will have five
days at your home
forge to accomplish this task.
After those five days, you will
return and present your weapons
to our panel of expert judges.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
Good luck to you, man.
We got this.
Day one here at my home forge,
and I'm ready to get started.
We're going to be building the--
makraka?
Am I saying it right?
One of the things I'm
most concerned about
is being able to
present to the judges
something that's worthy of
using it and testing it,
but I don't know.
It's a strange-looking weapon.
First, I'm going to go
for a Damascus blade.
It's got about 15
layers, I think.
So I'm going to throw
that in the forge
and bring it up to the
welding temperature.
What I'm hoping to see
when I press this billet
is that it takes the
weld immediately.
I mean, I don't want
to see any cold spots.
I can still see my joints.
I don't like that.
Before I go too far,
I'll grind it down
and see what it looks like.
If this doesn't go the way
I planned it, it is garbage.
I'll have to throw it
away and start over.
PAUL: Day two.
The biggest challenges
for today is
coming up with a quench tank.
This one's not going to work.
This one would be fine
for a big, long sword.
It's a big round sword.
So I've had to build
a new quench tank.
Perfect.
Oh yeah.
Now I'm in good shape.
So I'm going into
the heat treat.
It's so long.
With my forge, you can't heat
the whole blade at one time.
You have to kind of drift
it in and drift it out,
and it's kind of a chore,
but it's all I have.
Here we go.
It's not hard.
Son of a bitch.
If you don't have a hard
blade, all you've got
is a real pretty piece of
steel that looks like a knife.
Heat treating makraka, take two.
That drags pretty hard.
It's not hard again.
Take three.
God.
I failed not once, not
twice, three times.
Perhaps it's not the steel.
Perhaps it's my oil.
So a quick phone
call tells me there's
quenching oil in Springfield.
Road trip.
It's an incredible waste of
time, but I've got no choice.
Seems like I got my welds
real good on my billet,
so I'm going to try
forging this blade.
My plan for today is
to finish my forging.
I really want to
make sure I don't
draw this blade out too long.
Otherwise my arc
will be too high.
I don't want it to be
too much of a curve.
It's probably as straight
as I'm going to get it.
It's pretty vital to me to
get this heat treat going
and see just how this
blade's going to react.
All right, here we go.
I'm looking at my
heat-treating oven.
I know the blade isn't
going to fit in there.
It's wide enough, but
it's not long enough.
I'm going to try the torch.
Oh, I don't think I'm
going to be successful.
I've got to try something.
This might be all right.
I don't know.
It looks good.
I'm going to test it.
[bleep]
That blade broke.
Literally, there's no time
to think about the solution.
I'm just going to grab
that piece of leaf spring--
All right.
--start forging a blade.
Doesn't that get you?
Some guy in a poor,
third world country
can make stuff like this
that will withstand battle.
And I've got $70,000 worth of
equipment, and I can't do it.
PAUL: Day four.
I had to drive all day
to go get some more oil.
I got to get this
heat treat right.
Moment of truth here.
I sure hope it's hard.
That's the sound I've
been looking for.
My first oil was contaminated.
The new oil, it worked just
like it was supposed to.
Thank you.
I've lost way too much time
because of heat treating.
Fit and finish is my forte.
I don't have the
chance to do that now.
I am a little bit of
panic mode because my time
has dwindled away.
I'm going to have to
beat this thing up.
It has to be an
effective weapon.
CRAIG: I had to completely
forge another blade.
Now it's day five, and
I've got 20 hours left.
That will work.
I'm ready to heat treat.
The reason this blade
failed is because of what
I have to heat treat with.
I know the blade isn't
going to fit in there.
The plan is to leave a
small slit at the bottom
that the blade will
slide in and out of.
Let's give this a shot.
It looks nice.
If I don't get this blade heat
treated correctly, I'm done.
It definitely hardened.
Oh, what a relief.
I've got a blade I believe I
can take to the final round.
So now I've got to do a little
fitting on my handle material,
but I don't know if I have
enough time to finish.
Bladesmiths, to see
what kind of lethal damage
your weapon can do, I
will take your makraka
and I'll deliver lethal blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Craig, you're up first.
You ready?
CRAIG: Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
All right.
[music playing]
CRAIG: That's nasty.
You can mess somebody
up with that thing.
This is one of the lightest
swords I've ever picked up.
But the most important
thing, it will kill.
Thank you.
Paul, it's your turn.
I'm ready.
[music playing]
Well, Paul, where
one was speed,
this is power because
it's a lot heavier.
It dug in deep into
the chest cavity.
Overall, your makraka will kill.
Thank you.
Up next, the strength test.
Dave?
Gentlemen, an
advantage of that sword
was to actually reach
around the shield
hitting the man behind it.
So to test the strength and
durability of your blades,
I'm going to strike
these shields four times
with each of your weapons.
This kind of wood can withstand
extremely brutal force.
So remember, this
is not about what
your sword does to
the shield, but what
the shield does to your swords.
Now, Craig, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
DAVE: OK.
[music playing]
All right, I don't see
any nicks or damage.
The blade's still sharp.
Very nice.
Well done.
CRAIG: Thank you, sir.
Good job.
DAVE: All right.
Paul, you're up.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
DAVE: All right, Paul, I
don't see any blade damage.
The edge is in good shape.
I like the leather
wrap on the handle.
It's nice.
So all in all, nicely done.
PAUL: Thank you.
DAVE: Next up is
the sharpness test.
For that, I'll give
you back to Doug.
The makraka sword was
used by Azande warriors
for beheading their prisoners.
To see how sharp
your weapons are,
I'm going to do a mock
beheading over here.
Craig, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
DOUG: Let's do this.
All right.
[music playing]
Well, Craig, on a vertical
chop, it was easy to control.
My worry is about on a
horizontal chop or slice
that the weight would
put pressure on my wrist.
No issues whatsoever.
Overall, your blade will cut.
Thank you.
Paul you're up.
You're ready?
PAUL: Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
OK, Paul, the
feel of your blade
is a little bit on the
heavy side when you're
doing a horizontal slice.
It got hung up on
the watermelon,
almost cutting all
the way through them.
But on the vertical slice, it
just pulls you in and easily
cuts all the way through.
Your makraka will cut.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, in
just five days you've
done some exceptional work, and
your blades perform very well.
But in this arena
of competition,
there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion,
and that champion is--
Craig.
Congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Thank you, all.
Paul, your blade
did not make the cut.
Paul, you gave us
a powerful blade,
but you fell short on sharpness.
The bottom line,
it under-performed
the watermelons, and for that
reason, we have to let you go.
I accomplished
what I wanted to do.
There are guys on here that
have made thousands of blades
and didn't make it
as far as I did.
- Thanks, Paul.
- OK.
Take care, man.
PAUL: The first thing
I do when I get home
is I'm going to take a nap.
It was a hell of a week.
I lost 5 pounds.
Craig, you are the
"Forged in Fire" champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
I'm quite surprised.
I never thought
I'd get this far.
Why don't you present
your blade to the judges?
CRAIG: I certainly didn't
walk away with this.
Paul put up a fight,
but I could come there
with the best-looking thing,
but if it doesn't perform,
then you're out.